la séance est ouverte
le compte-rendu intégral de la séance du
mercredi 25 janvier
a été publié sur le site internet du
Sénat
y a-t-il des observations
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal est
donc adopté
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
avant d'aborder notre ordre du jour
je souhaite
saluer la mémoire d'un grand résistant
qui fut aussi un fonctionnaire
exemplaire de notre institution
Jacques bloc
directeur d'honoraires du service des
commissions du Sénat
nous a quittés le 28 janvier dernier
né dans une famille qui avait quitté
l'Alsace-Lorraine pour rester françaises
il était entré dans la Résistance à
l'âge de 20 ans
joue un rôle de premier plan
dans la libération notamment de la ville
de Guéret
grièvement blessé il fut capturé
livré à la Gestapo
torturé avant d'être déportés à Vald
puis rejoint les forces armées
américaines et revenir en France
intégrer au Conseil de la République
dès 1946
il a servi l'administration sénatoriale
pendant plus de 40 ans
quand
recueillant les éloges unanimes de nos
prédécesseurs et de ses collègues pour
son dévouement et la qualité de son
travail
pour ces actes d'héroïsme Jacques bloc
fut nommé Commandeur de l'Ordre de la
Légion d'honneur par décret du général
de Gaulle
même si vous ne l'avez pas connu
[Musique]
la cérémonie aux plaques du 11 novembre
jusqu'en 2020
il fut toujours présent
petite silhouette
suite de ces tortures un bras pour
partir en moins
il était toujours fidèle à cette
cérémonie et à cet engagement alors je
voulais au nom du Sénat d'aujourd'hui au
nom du Sénat tout entier connu rendu
hommage à la mémoire d'un homme qui
incarnera à tout jamais le courage et
l'abnégation au service de la France et
de valeurs que nous portons ensemble
dans notre diversité
je vous remercie
chers collègues au nom au regard du
nombre d'amendements déposés sur les
textes inscrits à l'ordre du jour de cet
après-midi
et en accord avec le gouvernement et les
commissions concernées nous pourrions
d'une part reporter à demain soir
mercredi 1er février l'examen de la
profession de loi visant à calculer la
retraite de base des non salariés
agricoles en fonction des 25 années
d'assurance des plus avantageuses
examens initialement prévus en dernier
point de notre ordre du jour de la
journée d'autre part d'ouvrir la nuit de
ce soir et prévoir une éventuelle
suite de l'examen de la promotion de loi
visant à protéger les logements contre
l'occupation illicite le jeudi 2 février
après-midi à l'issue de l'espace réservé
au groupe écologie solidarité territoire
et éventuellement le soir y a-t-il des
observations sur l'organisation de ces
débats pour nous permettre d'examiner
ces différentes propositions dans les
meilleures conditions possibles je
n'envoie point il en est assis décidé
l'ordre du jour appelle les explications
de vote des groupes et le vote par
scrutin public sur la neige sur le
projet de loi relatif aux Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 je
rappelle que la procédure accélérée a
été engagée sur ce texte et je donne
immédiatement la parole et pour cette
minute
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoires
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur prudent madame la Nice
le 26 juillet 2024 la série d'ouverture
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques
marquera le début d'une grande fête
populaire
célébrée dans tous les territoires
ruraux
tous les Français seront au rendez-vous
et ne seront pas les seuls
plus de 4000 athlètes
athlètent paralympique et 10500 athlètes
olympiques s'affront devant 4 milliards
de téléspectateurs
au-delà de son ampleur et de attendre
qu'il génère cet événement est inédit à
plus d'un titre
il aboie
que représente la série d'ouverture en
plein air
il a ensuite inédit par son exemplarité
écologique puisque nous accueillerons
les premiers jeux alignés sur les
objectifs de l'accord de Paris
cet événement est enfin inédit par son
exemplarité en matière de parité et
d'inclusion
déjà
en 1924 les jeux de paris Marc et
l'histoire en ouvrant pour la première
fois les portes aux athlètes féminines
100 ans plus tard la France se démarque
encore en leur donnant les premiers jeux
strictement paritaires
je souhaite également faire un clin
d'oeil aux prises nos deux mascottes
partisagement technique nous rendons
notre droit conforme pardon
pour la première fois les mascottes
olympiques et olympiques sont identiques
avec une prothèse visible pour la
seconde malgré les apparences cela n'a
rien à
nous aurons beaucoup de joie et
d'émotions à accueillir pour la première
fois aussi en France ces jeux et admirer
la tête concourir au Grand Palais pour
les skins fauteuil au château de
Versailles pour les épreuves de parents
équitation ou encore au Champ de Mars
pour le rugby fauteuil
en aimant des jeux ce texte propose de
nouvelles dispositions en matière de
lutte contre le dopage
de sécurité d'adaptation à l'Outre-mer
ainsi que des mesures sanitaires
par ces ajustements techniques nous
rendons notre droit conforme aux
exigences du Comité international
olympique les apports du Sénat vendant
le beau sens et permettent d'apporter
quelques précisions nécessaires nous
pouvons nous en féliciter
dans le cas de la lutte contre le dopage
le Sénat a favoriser la collaboration
avec l'Agence française de lutte contre
le dopage et de la cellule du
renseignement financier national
nous avons aussi pérennisé la postée de
procédés à des tests génétiques c'est
une bonne chose car nous vont adapter
nos méthodes de détection aux pratiques
dopant qui rivalisent d'innovation
ainsi nous disons
identifierons pleinement et plus
facilement ceux qui oseraient briser le
serment olympique
le Sénat a voté plusieurs millions de
simplification
parmi elles nous avons facilité l'accès
aux autorisations de stationnement
spécifique
pour les taxis aux abords des jeux des
endroits des Jeux Olympiques
il est essentiel également d'être
exigeant sur la question d'accès aux
équipements et aux épreuves
le Sénat a également simplifié cette
procédure permettant de déroger au repos
dominical
c'est d'adaptation temporaire au droit
du travail permettra au commerce
concerné de bénéficier pleinement de
l'afflux des visiteurs
durant les prochains mois la France va
accueillir plusieurs événements de
grande ampleur
ces jeux bien sûr olympiques et
paralympique sont parmi les plus
regardés
pour l'image notre pays mais aussi et
surtout pour le concitoyen et pour les
visiteurs nous devons assurer que en
toute sécurité
nos forces de l'ordre sont pleinement
mobilisés dans la préparation de ces
jeunes
elles auront besoin de renfort
la sécurité privée constituera à cet
égard un atout précieux
en plus d'effectif suffisant il nous
semble nécessaire que ceux qui nous
protègent puissent employer les
meilleurs outils
le trade le traitement algorithmique et
de la vidéoprotection a suscité beaucoup
de débats
nous pensons une avancée majeure pour la
détection des troubles à l'ordre public
que ce soit des mouvements de foule ou
des menaces terroristes
comme toute technologie il y en a
néanmoins nécessaires d'encadrer
strictement son utilisation pour
protéger au mieux les libertés
individuelles de nos concitoyens
nous nous félicitons que la CNIL soit
étroitement associée à son développement
vous me servez par ailleurs le texte
renforce également les sanctions
concernant les intrusions dans les
stades
nous saluons ces mesures il faut cesser
d'instrumentaliser le sport à des fins
politiques
c'est un espace de rassemblement où il
faut mettre en avant ce qui nous
rapproche plutôt que ceux qui nous
divisent
pour ces différentes raisons la
modification Sénat de l'antiquité du
texte désormais plus ouvert permet de
rendre compte de la diversité des
dispositions prévues pour permettre aux
jeux de se dérouler dans de très bonnes
conditions
enfin si les jours en eux-mêmes
représentent un événement majeur
que nous sommes fiers d'accueillir il
est essentiel de préparer la suite
la polyderitage et ça a durabilité dans
le temps sont essentielles en effet quel
meilleur occasion que ces jeux pour
faire de la France une nation sportive
il attire rappeler madame la ministre
que l'actif physique et sportive a été
régie en grande cause nationale en 2024
j'en suis heureux pour nos jeunes
pour qui l'augmentation du temps dédiée
au sport dans les écoles primaires et
les collèges mais aussi
pour la conscience du passeport son
excellente nouvelle également heureux
pour le moins jeune si j'ose dire car
nous connaissons les vertus de la
pratique sportive pour la santé
en 2024 la France avait déjà rempoté 38
médailles dont 13 en or en 2024 nous
sommes certains en 2024 certains que
nous athlètes olympiques et
paralympiques représenteront fièrement
nos couleurs cette confiance que nous
pouvons le redresser nos encouragements
pour le dernier mois de préparation
les Jeux Olympiques ne sont pas
seulement des compétitions sportives ce
sont aussi des temps des temps de
fraternité d'échanges et de découverte
des temps d'émerveillement aussi nous
devons relever ce défi ensemble aussi
les groupes
et appels à la mission de tous pour
célébrer ensemble le sport ces valeurs
et ses adeptes dans les meilleures
conditions je vous remercie suivre
la parole
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant notre collègue Guy
menaroche pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame et monsieur le
rapporteur cher collègue les semaines et
les mois passent et leur voler sécurité
de ce gouvernement ne retombe jamais
l'examen en séance de ce projet de loi a
démontré par bien des aspects les réels
motifs d'un véhicule législatif dans le
but n'est pas tort l'adaptation de
certaines de nos règles pour un
déroulement serein des épreuves des Jeux
olympiques mais bien essentiellement la
mise en œuvre de nouveaux outils
sécuritaires poursuivant la dérive de ce
gouvernement vers une société de
surveillance nous l'avons déjà exposé
mon collègue Thomas dessus la défendu
avec cohérence et sincérité quel est le
cœur de ce projet de loi une mise en
concordance du droit de la santé pour
des questions de dopage une réécriture
du Code de l'Urbanisme pour le
développement futur du sport dans nos
territoires délégieux non il n'en est
rien nous aurions pu être à vos côtés
madame lavidis pour soutenir les
fédérations et le sport amateur comme
professionnel qui voit dans les JO la
vitrine qui saurait accélérer la
pratique sportive dans toute sa
diversité vous aurions aussi aimé débats
de sérieusement de l'impact de cet
événement sur notre tissu de festival et
d'événements culturels sur les surcos et
les difficultés pour les organisateurs
ou les collectivités sur l'utilisation
culturelle sportive environnementale de
l'exposition offerte à notre nation par
cette vitrine ouverture sur le monde en
fait de vitrine nous aurons une phrase
sous-cloche comme le crème à collag
modique de Barco la vie les autres
activités continueront pendant ces jeux
et la sécurisation de ces autres
événements outre surcoût pour leurs
organisateurs souffrira d'un risque de
précipitation et de formation
insuffisante nous avons eu l'occasion de
le dire quelle étrange texte centrée sur
les JO et sur les Jeux paralympiques qui
contenus de 80% de mesures pérennes
des aspects les plus remarquables des
articles les abonnements étudiés et
voter consiste dans la mise en oeuvre
sur un temps long de mesures censées
d'être nécessaire que pour le bon
déroulement des jeux cette loi impact
bien plus loin que l'organisation des
Jeux qu'en est-il de ce cheval de Troie
sécurité
notre groupe regrette une nouvelle fois
une vision débridée et si éloignée des
valeurs de l'eau lapisme la
disproportion des mesures pour la
sécurité en jeu dans ce texte cache de
réalisateurs au droit des personnes qui
s'inscrivent bien au-delà du temps des
jeux j'ai pu l'exprimer tout se
déploiement de la vision sécurité les
recours massifs et presque
indifférentiel la vidéo surveillance
augmentée pose de nombreuses questions
durée de l'expérimentation finalité de
l'expérimentation à venir des
apprentissages de ces machines contrôle
de mécanismes algorithmique dangereux
potentiel mis à disposition pour
d'autres opérateurs non nationaux plus
ou moins respectueux des droits de leur
citoyens la CNIL dit dans son
positionnement plus que prudent sur ces
technologies quelles sont susceptibles
d'affecter les garanties fondamentales
apportées aux citoyens pour l'exercice
des libertés publiques
c'est bien une vision sécuritaire
technologique qui se dévoile et que nous
jugeons d'autant plus néfaste et
inefficace qu'elle Auber complètement le
terrain car sur le terrain que se
passe-t-il le recrutement la formation
des agents de sécurité n'a pas été
anticipé nous allons manquer de
personnel public et privés le recours à
l'armée madame la ministre ne va pas
tarder à être annoncé la cour des côtes
estime qu'il faudrait employer 22 villes
à 33000 agents de sécurité privée par
jour pour véritablement sécuriser
l'ensemble des épreuves ces chiffres-là
dépassent largement les capacités
disponibles dans les entreprises de la
région et du pays les crêtes de voir sur
le terrain des gens peu formés face à
des événements du tel ampleur laisse
inévitablement resurgir le spectre du
fiasco du Stade de France
il est vrai qu'il est difficile de
retenir les leçons d'un événement que le
gouvernement a toujours considéré comme
bien géré bien préparé ce déni coupable
ne doit pas être l'occasion de manquer
de remettre en cause et de faire
progresser les techniques de matière de
l'Orbe et de la gestion des flux de
population au delà des crêtes de la mise
en place de mesures sécurité
disproportionnées rien dans ce texte de
vie éloigner le doute d'une explosion
des coûts comparable à l'expérience
londonienne ce texte ne s'attarde pas et
ne s'inquiète pas de l'étude du triste
héritage financier budgétaire que
pourrait laisser les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques le dernier rapport de la
Cour des comptes alertes pourtant
clairement sur un budget qui n'est
toujours pas connu eux qui les
précisément pas établi mais on nous a
dit que ça allait être bientôt et rien
ne rassure vraiment les collectivités
hautes d'événement sur les garanties
financières que devrait leur apporter
l'État
il est également regrettable que les
collectivités qui se sont engagées
pleinement dans le projet olympique soit
bises de côté pour des décisions
pratiques comme nous l'avions demandé
par exemple au travers de l'exercice
temporaire de pouvoir de police de
circulation et de stationnement décision
qui permettrait de limiter l'impact
environnemental des jeux
l'impact environnementale annoncé comme
cheval de bataille de ce gouvernement
mais que n'a-t-il pas été annoncé sur ce
terrain par Emmanuel Macron et ses
gouvernements depuis bientôt 6 ans sans
être suivi de mesure à la hauteur des
enjeux vitaux impactent aussi sur la
qualité de vie des riverains des jeux
qui en plus de ne pas être sûr de
pouvoir participer et assister à cette
fête devra subir l'invasion de la
publicité dans un cadre anormalement
dérogatoire aux règles du droit commun
en vigueur les entreprises partenaires
sont ainsi autorisées à afficher sur les
bouts du bon historique les espaces
naturels et à peu près tous les éléments
qui leur conviennent dans un périmètre
de 500 mètres autour de chaque site
d'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
partenaire
dans certains pour en faire feu sans
retenue alors qu'ils sont notament
répertoriés pour leurs actions néfastes
à l'environnement et au changement
climatique est-ce vraiment des jeux pour
l'environnement par essentiel du
dacitation à quoi subarisme débridés ces
affichages ont des conséquences
environnementales que nous acceptons pas
en temps normal alors que nous avons
offert réussi à limiter la pollution
visuelle des Pado lumineux ces
dérogations prises au moment même où
l'État incite à la sobriété énergétique
non pas de sens à croire que nous
pouvons mettre tout cela entre
parenthèses le temps des jeux quelle
hérésie
nous avons tenté au travers de plusieurs
abonnements de recentrer la loi sur ce
qu'elle devrait être l'encadrement des
JO et non sur ce Calais une dérive
sécurité pérenne au détriment du droit
des citoyens certains positions étaient
entendus par la commission et par le
Gouvernement très peu trop peu la
plupart ne l'ont pas été l'équilibre du
texte n'a pas été modifié nous mettra
une analyse d'un texte trop dangereux
pour les libertés individuelles aux
objectifs réels qui auraient nécessité
une concertation et de confrontation sur
elle de vision différente sur la
sécurité globale de notre société en
fait sur notre modèle de société pour
toutes ces raisons notre groupe ventra
contre ce projet de loi
merci mon cher collègue la parole de
notre collègue Didier Rambaud pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues le compte à rebours est lancé
dans 542 jours 4 heures et 9 minutes une
fête unique débutera dans notre pays
celle des jeux de 2024 une aventure
sportive incomparable qui fera la fierté
des Françaises et des Français et plus
encore s'il arrive à la hauteur de nos
ambitions à savoir une fête sportive
populaire dans l'héritage deviendrait le
symbole d'un nouveau modèle de jeu sobre
durable et inclusifs les jeux n'étant
pas un événement sportif comme les
autres de nombreuses questions se posent
quant à son organisation raison pour
laquelle nous devrons prendre toutes les
précautions pour assurer son bon
déroulement si je crois l'esprit de ce
projet de loi un texte qui répond à de
multiples enjeux et qui ne méritent par
conséquent pas l'appellation de textes
sécuritaire une fois encore les
arguments soulevés par le groupe
écologiste sont tout à fait contestables
exprimé des inquiétudes ou des
désaccords quant à la vidéo protection
et à ses usages c'est une chose mais
qualifier ce texte de copie techno
sécuritaire c'est autre chose résumé ce
projet de loi un texte qui ne traiterait
que de la sécurité est faux et d'une
certaine manière c'est même injuste
alors certes il est question de sécurité
dans ce projet de loi oui le texte vient
renforcer nos dispositifs de sécurité
avec l'expérimentation d'un dispositif
de vidéoprotection ayant recours à
l'intelligence artificielle non la ligne
rouge de la reconnaissance faciale n'a
pas été franchie exigence du recours au
contrôle humain système de gestion des
risques accompagnement et contrôle de la
CNIL dans le développement et
l'application des traitements autant de
garantie supplémentaires adopté par
notre assemblée qui permettront dériver
d'éviter les dérives liberticides que
vous craignez tout autant que nous
oui le projet de loi permet de mettre en
place des scanners corporels à l'entrée
des enceintes qui accueilleront plus de
300 spectateurs à l'image de ceux qui
existent déjà dans les aéroports parce
que c'est une mesure intrusive là encore
nous apportons des garanties
supplémentaires à l'image de
l'amendement pour tes collègue Dominique
Théophile exigeant du recueillir
obligatoirement le consentement express
des personnes contrôlées par ces
scanners un amendement adopté qui
apporte une garantie non négligeable une
garantie parmi d'autres tels que
l'impossibilité matérielle de
reconnaître un visage ou encore
l'interdiction du stockage et de
l'enregistrement des images oui le
projet de loi renforce notre arsenal
juridique pour assurer la sécurité de
tous et la tranquillité des épreuves
olympiques et paralympiques nous devons
tirer des enseignements des incidents
passés afin d'éviter qu'ils ne se
reproduisent raison pour laquelle
l'obligation de présenter un titre
d'accès pour entrer dans une enceinte
sportive et l'obligation pour les
organisateurs des manifestations les
plus importantes de recourir à des
billets nominatifs dématérialisés et
infasifiable sont à mes yeux des mesures
justifiées et proportionnées par
conséquent non nous ne sommes pas dans
l'assurance cher sécuritaire il s'agit
d'apporter des précisions juridiques
utiles ou juge qui appliqueront et
respecteront les principes
d'individualisation et de
proportionnalité des peines oui ce
projet de loi met en oeuvre des moyens
nécessaires afin d'assurer la sécurité
des jeux des participants et du public
rappelons également que ces textes
traduit certaines des recommandations
figurant dans le rapport d'information
du Sénat sur les incidents survenus au
Stade de France en mai dernier mais
comme l'ont démontré nos débats mes
chers collègues ce texte répond aussi à
des enjeux liés à la santé au sport et à
l'organisation des Jeux sur le plan
sanitaire d'abord en proposant une
adaptation de l'offre de soins et de
premiers secours je pense à la création
de la polyclinique olympique et
paralympique sans centre de santé unique
au cœur du village je pense également au
professionnel de santé étrangers qui
pourront bénéficier d'une autorisation
d'exercice dans le cadre des jeux ou
encore la possibilité pour d'autres
acteurs que les associations agrées de
la sécurité civile de délivrer des
formations au premier secours ce texte
protège également les valeurs de
l'olympisme à travers la lutte contre le
dopage en autorisant le recours au test
génétique des tests réalisés par le
laboratoire antidopage français de
l'Université de Paris Saclay qui seront
utilisés par l'International testing
agency à qui le CIO a confié la mission
de contrôle antidopage mes chers
collègues le projet de loi apporte aussi
des réponses aux enjeux liés à
l'organisation des Jeux pensons à la
mise en œuvre de la dérogation au repos
médical qui saura je le rappelle
conditionner au respect du volontariat
des salariés ainsi qu'à l'octroi des
contreparties légales prévues dans le
code du travail les communes situées à
proximité des sites de compétition ont
été intégrés à juste titre pour éviter
tout risque de rupture d'égalité entre
les entreprises notamment les communes
qui sans être limitrophes aurait pu
avoir une influence de touristes je
pense également à la mutualisation des
moyens de la solideo avec ceux de grands
Paris aménagement je pense enfin à
l'attribution de nouvelles autorisations
de stationnement pour les taxis
accessibles aux personnes utilisatrices
de fauteuils roulant alors oui mes chers
collègues il est bien il est bel et bien
question de sécurité dans ce projet de
loi mais n'oublions pas de préciser
qu'il est aussi question de sport de
santé et d'organisation en témoignent
les modifications bienvenues qui ont été
adoptées par notre assemblée en
commission ont commencé ensemble parmi
les apports du Sénat soulignant la
clarification du statut dérogatoire de
la polyclinique ainsi que la possibilité
pour les volontaires olympiques et
paralympiques de participer aux missions
du centre de santé je pense également à
l'autorisation des échanges
d'informations entre l'Agence française
de lutte contre le dopage et traite fin
la cellule de renseignements financier
dans France française je pense au droit
pour les personnels affectés à des
missions de maintien ou de renforcement
de la sécurité pendant les jeux de
retrouver leur affectation antérieure
une fois l'événement achevé notre
Assemblée a également voté des mesures
significatives en matière de lutte
contre le dopage à l'image de la
pérennisation des tests génétiques au
sein de lutte contre le dopage
permettant de mettre en conformité notre
code du sport avec le code mondial
antidopage une lutte qui sera renforcée
en Polynésie française grâce à
l'extension de certaines mesures
d'enquêtes saluons enfin la proposition
du rapport de la Cour des comptes sur
l'organisation le coût et l'héritage des
jeux qui permettra de mettre en lumière
le travail colossal qui est mené en la
matière et de suivre son solutions en
définitive mes chers collègues nos
débats ont je crois permis de préserver
l'équilibre de ce texte tout en
enrichissant sur de nombreux aspects
loin de toute polémiques le groupe RDP
votera donc pour ce projet de loi qui
nous rassemblera sans doute seront un
point l'impatience d'assister à ces jeux
olympiques et par Olympiques qui
s'annonce d'Orient déjà historique si
mon cher collègue
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme du
Rhin pour le groupe socialiste
écologique et républicain
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président madame le
rapporteur madame la ministre en mars
2018 le Parlement était saisi d'un
projet de Loire relatif à l'organisation
des Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
2024 le Sénat s'était prononcé à
l'unanimité en faveur de l'adoption de
ce premier texte c'est unanimité
témoignait de la volonté quel que soit
les bancs de réussir Paris 2024
5 années plus tard et un an et demi
avant les Jeux de Paris voici le
Parlement à nouveau saisi d'un projet de
loi s'il était initialement affublé du
même titre le Sénat accepté nos demandes
on ajoute tant à son intitulé La
précision suivante portant diverses
autres dispositions ce n'est pas anodin
nous souhaitons toujours comme
l'ensemble des sénateurs et sénatrices
de cette hémicycle la réussite des jeux
cette réussite passe-t-elle par
l'adoption de ce texte alors il y a bon
nombre de mesures très utiles présentes
dans les 24 articles de ce projet de loi
ainsi les adaptations nécessaires en
matière d'offre de soins et de formation
premiers secours sont compréhensibles on
perçoit bien la nécessité d'avoir un
centre de santé au sein du Village
Olympique tout comme la possibilité de
former davantage de monde au premier
secours
le chapitre consacré à la lutte contre
le dopage est d'importance
l'autorisation de l'examen des
caractéristiques génétiques ou de la
comparaison des empreintes génétiques
pour les analyses antidopage a provoqué
de vives débats dans l'hémicycle nous
nous félicitons de l'adoption de
l'amendement de notre collègue Lauzac
qui prévoit un échange d'informations
entre l'Agence française de lutte contre
le dopage et track fin le chapitre 5
évite le recours aux ordonnances pour
l'application en outre-mer cela devient
une habitude légistique sénatoriale et
c'est un progrès indéniable l'un des
enjeux principaux mis en avant par le
gouvernement concerne la sécurité de ses
Jeux Olympiques alors que notre pays
reste confronté à des menaces
d'envergure nous comprenons que
l'exécutif consacre beaucoup de
ressources à cette problématique nous
comprenons la recherche d'efficacité en
donnant plus de pouvoir au préfet nous
comprenons la mise en conformité du
régime de la vidéoprotection avec le
droit européen sur la protection des
données nous sommes donc prêts à
comprendre beaucoup de choses mais cela
ne veut pas dire que nous soyons prêts à
tout accepter ce qui nous intéresse dans
ce texte ce sont les Jeux Olympiques et
les Jeux paralympiques pourtant
plusieurs mesures qui sont présentées
comme étant des expérimentations
temporaires sont amenées à être
pérennisé au-delà de la seule échéance
des jeux cela est fait de la volonté du
gouvernement mais c'est aussi le
résultat de plusieurs évolutions portées
par la majorité sénatoriale le Sénat a
retiré tout caractère expérimental à la
possibilité pour le laboratoire
antidopage français de procéder à des
tests génétiques sur les échantillons
prélevés sur les sportifs pourtant la
mise en oeuvre de ces mesures qui déroge
au disposition du Code civil
issus des lois bioéthiques aurait mérité
un débat approfondi et une expertise
pluraliste que l'unique rapport
d'évaluation envisagée par la majorité
sénatoriale ne peut suffire à combler
sur la vidéo surveillance automatisée la
position de la majorité sénatoriale
aboutit à préjugé de la pérennisation de
cette technique de contrôle qui
constitue un véritable tournant en
matière de sécurité publique en votant
la durée de l'expérimentation bien
au-delà de la période des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de 2024 en
annonçant d'ores et déjà sa reconduction
voir son application définitive ce texte
olympique défini dans notre pays un
nouveau standard de sécurité même rendu
plus précis par les travaux de notre
chambre même en prévoyant un droit
d'information du public renforcé nous
considérons qu'il ne s'agit pas du bon
véhicule législatif pour porter des
choix aussi lourds par ailleurs
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques de
2024 constitue un prétexte pour apporter
une solution sécuritaire à des problèmes
de maintien de l'ordre au sein des
stades et renforcer démesurément les
peines applicables alors même qu'un
groupe de dissertation entre
représentants des supporters et des
ministères concernés est à l'oeuvre des
associations de supporters dont on peut
considérer qu'ils sont des amis du monde
sportif ont ainsi exprimé leur plus vif
inquiétudes quant au contenu de cette
loi les articles 12 et 12 bis sous
l'initiative de la droite sénatoriale
sont d'autant plus malvenus que
l'exécutif soit-elle restaurer le
dialogue avec les supporters ces
dernières années faut-il donc envisager
des peines de prison si des militants
envahissent le Stade de France pour
porter un message politique au groupe
socialiste nous sommes conscients que
parfois la politique s'invite dans le
sport à l’inverse du président Macron et
nous ne pouvons pas accepter des
dispositifs proposés qui nous paraissent
inutilement durci quant au chapitre 4
consacré au dispositions diverses
reconnaissons qu'il a abouti à des
discussions parfois cavalières pourtant
plusieurs de nos amendements qui avaient
un lien direct avec la réussite des Jeux
Olympiques ont eux aussi étaient jugés
recevable les transports en commun
parisien la taxe de séjour dans les
hôtels de luxe des villes hautes le
travail le dimanche dans les communes
concernées par les jeux l'affectation
renfort humain pourra sécurisé pour
assurer la sécurité des JO autant de
sujets dont nous n'avons pas pu débattre
alors qu'ils auraient enrichi
utilement nos débats le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
est entré dans la discussion
parlementaire de manière constructive
souhaitant je le répète la réussite des
jeux nous le souhaitons toujours mais le
texte déposé par le Gouvernement comme
la discussion en commission puis dans
l'hémicycle non pas levé tous nos doutes
des inquiétudes légitimes notamment
autour de l'article 7 ont beaucoup
crispé et nos doutes demeure le bilan
est donc mitigé face à l'accumulation
d'expérimentation que nous considérons
mal encadré et pas assez restreinte nous
faisons le choix de l'abstention
exigeante à ce stade de l'examen du
texte la réussite de Paris 2024 ne
justifie pas que l'on accepte des recul
présent ici ou là dans cette loi nous
suivrons avec vigilance la navette
parlementaire espérant notamment être
rassuré sur les moyens mis à disposition
de ces jeux sur la préservation de
l'agenda culturel 2024 et espérance
surtout que les expérimentations
envisagées dans ce texte seront
davantage encadrés
merci
la parole de la présidente Eliane
assassine pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologiste
madame la Présidente
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues à
l'occasion de l'examen de ce projet de
loi nous avions nous avons exprimé de
fortes réserves face à un texte qui nous
parle davantage de sécurité que de sport
face à des enjeux réels de sécurité mais
aussi de rayonnement international vous
avez subrepticement introduit un
florilège de disposition attentatoires
aux libertés et droits fondamentaux le
problème est bien que ces dispositions
sont vouées à être pérennisées nous
avons tiré la sonnette d'alarme pourtant
le gouvernement a décidé d'être sourd
mon groupe rappelle que l'exception doit
demeurer temporaire et nous regrettons
qu'avec ce projet de loi l'exception
soit banalisée et rentrera finalement
dans le droit commun nous refusons
d'adhérer à la vision que vous nous
proposez des JO et des jop sous prétexte
de sécuriser l'événement ce texte ouvre
la boîte de Pandore ou à des atteintes
au droit les plus fondamentaux
avec les nouvelles technologies que vous
nous proposez l'heure est au détricotage
du rgpd nous passons un cap nous sommes
face à un laboratoire juridique et
sécuritaire que nous rejetons fermement
jusqu'où pouvons-nous aller dans la
teinte aux libertés individuelles sans
mettre le moteur des expérimentations
que vous nous proposez les droits
fondamentaux sont niés par la
vidéourveillance algorithmique et nos
fortes réserves n'ont pas été prises en
considération cela est bien regrettable
la France étant jusqu'ici en pointe dans
le domaine du rgpd les droits
fondamentaux ne doivent pas s'effacer au
profit d'expérimentation sécuritaire
n'oublions pas que l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle et pour leur
dépourvu de cadre légal même si un
règlement européen est en cours
d'élaboration n'oublions pas non plus
que l'expérimentation ne nous garantit
aucun résultat comme son nom l'indique
on teste en effet mais on ne connaît pas
son efficacité le droit au respect de la
vie privée est ici balayée d'un simple
revers de main je suis au regret de vous
dire qu'on ne bat pas ainsi les droits
fondamentaux en procédant de la sorte
vous entachez la popularité des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 cette magnifique est
belle compétition porteuse de valeurs
universelle c'est pourquoi nous nous
sommes opposés à votre durcissement
sécuritaire tout azimut et ce même et ce
même dans le cadre des manifestations
sportives nous avons proposé de rendre
proportionnées certaines mesures comme
le pointage ou encore vous montrer
méthodiquement comment le tour estressif
notamment en matière d'engins
pyrotechnique en plus d'être inopérant
va même à l'encontre du but poursuivi à
savoir la sécurité des supporters pour
nous le sport et ces manifestations
constituent des moments festifs et de
joie spontanée bref une communion
populaire à l'état pur or votre penchant
sécuritaire dans l'encadrement des
manifestations sportives directement
inspirées de la gestion des Coupe du
monde en Russie au Qatar ne feront que
sapés un élan populaire spontané pour un
événement sportif majeur de plus comme
nous l'avions dénoncé dans notre motion
d'y recevabilité le recours aux agents
de sécurité privée pour encadrer ces JO
ne sera pas à la hauteur des enjeux la
sécurité privée ne doit pas être
confondue avec la sécurité étatique au
risque de se solder par un cuisant échec
tel qu'essuyer par les JO de Londres en
2012 cette délégation nonora ni
l'événement ni les professions de la
sécurité publique par ailleurs ce texte
aurait dû constituer un engagement du
gouvernement pour entreprendre une
politique volontariste en matière de
sport l'héritage économique et social
des jeux fut au mieux survolé durant les
débats pour ne pas dire totalement
évacué et pourtant quel meilleur moment
que celui ou se tiendront les jeux pour
casser les barrières sociales
territoriales ou encore celle liées au
handicap entre
usagers et pratiques sportives le sport
madame la ministre c'est un enjeu
culturel et ce tant au niveau
professionnel qu'au niveau amateur si
effectivement les jeux mettent à
l'honneur nos athlètes de haut niveau et
à travers eux nos fédérations sportives
ne pas réfléchir à l'après en matière
d'accessibilité de la pratique sportive
pour tous et toutes je vous le dis
madame la ministre c'est du gâchis enfin
s'agissant de l'accueil des jeux dans
nos des jeux notre groupe a posé la
question lors des débats de
l'anticipation des besoins en matière de
capacité d'accès aux soins des hôpitaux
avec la présence de milliers de
supporters du monde entier l'afflux de
patients dans les hôpitaux de
l'Assistance publique hôpitaux de Paris
dont 15% des lits sont actuellement
fermées par manque de personnel
paramédical
ensuite une anticipation des besoins par
l'État les besoins supplémentaires en
lit d'hopitaux et de recrutement de
personnels doivent être immédiatement
suivies de mesures tout en garantissant
le niveau d'accès aux soins pour les
patients franciliens si les besoins ne
sont pas suffisamment anticipés l'agence
régionale de santé devra déclencher le
plan blanc pour mobiliser l'ensemble du
personnel hospitalier cela entraînera
deux facto la suspension des congés pour
le personnel hospitalier comme cela est
d'ailleurs prévu pour les forces de
l'ordre n'oublions pas que
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques va également impacter
fortement la vie des fonctionnaires mais
également des salariés auxquels il sera
demandé de travailler les dimanches
autour des sites de compétition alors
même que l'évaluation de la loi Macron
de 2015 qui a déréglementé le travail du
dimanche dans les zones commerciales les
zones touristiques les zones
touristiques internationales et les gars
a démontré que l'ouverture du travail le
dimanche on a entraîné aucune hausse de
l'emploi ou de l'activité nous soutenons
que la remise en cause du repos
dominical pour les salariés est un geste
d'antigeux sur nos droits sociaux pour
conclure le groupe CRCE considère que ce
projet de loi libéral et sécuritaire ne
respectent pas le juste équilibre entre
sécurité et protection des libertés et
droits fondamentaux il n’honore pas les
Jeux Olympiques et son esprit de
fraternité en ce qu'il porte de graves
atteintes aux libertés publiques ainsi
vous ne serez pas surprise madame la
ministre le groupe serre votre a contre
ce projet de loi
merci madame la Présidente
de donner la parole de notre collègue
Arnaud de belnay pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
il y avait la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre mesdames les rapporteurs
monsieur le rapporteur chers collègues
nous avons adopté en 2018 une première
loi sur l'organisation des Jeux
Olympiques elle comprenait déjà un
certain nombre de mesures visant à
répondre au contraintes de
l'organisation d'un événement d'une
telle ampleur et à moins de deux ans des
Jeux Olympiques il était nécessaire
d'adopter plusieurs mesures
complémentaires
particulièrement matière de dopage de
sécurité de santé et quelques autres
mesures d'ordre d'hiver le groupe Union
centriste est favorable à l'adoption de
ce texte qui a été
perfectionné par le travail de la
commission des lois et des deux autres
commissions saisies pour avis
celle des affaires sociales celle de la
culture et puis bien évidemment
perfectionner dans cette émission à
l'article 4 la rapporteur Agnès canaille
a eu la subtilité de nous proposer un
compromis qui prend en compte la
nécessité d'une mise en conformité
pérenne du droit français avec le code
mondial entier dopage tout en conservant
la prudence nécessaire en matière
d'examen des caractéristiques génétiques
le Sénat a fait preuve affai oeuvre
constructive concernant l'article 7 sur
la vidéoprotection qualifiée d'augmenter
puisqu'il s'est vu consolider tant
commission par l'introduction de
garanties supplémentaires à tous les
moments du développement et du
déploiement de ces dispositifs que dans
l'hémicycle par l'adoption de deux
amendements de nos collègues du Rhin et
Tabarro qui vise à plus de transparence
des fournisseurs en exigeant une
déclaration d'intérêt et du personnel
pour le recrutement
en discussion générale je me suis réjoui
que le Gouvernement et la commission des
lois et eu la justement l'intelligence
de ne recourir à cette IA quatre titres
expérimental de manière limitée limitée
dans le temps limité dans l'espace
limiter à un cadre restreint et sans
aucune utilisation de données
biométriques il n'y a là aucune atteinte
au droit fondamentaux
les données personnelles sont protégées
puisqu'elles ne sont ni traitées ni
stockées ni collecter
néanmoins cela ne nous dispensera pas et
c'est l'objet de la proposition 22 de la
mission d'information sur la
reconnaissance biométrique menée
conjointement avec Jérôme Durin et Marc
Philippe daubrais de créer au-delà des
Jeux Olympiques un cadre juridique
expérimental pour recourir à la
reconnaissance biométrique en temps réel
sur la voie publique sur la base d'une
menace pré-identifiée éventuellement il
nous faudra déposer une proposition de
loi afin de permettre un débat serein
apaisé enfin sur ces sujets et
démocratiques bien sûr sur ces questions
d'avenir parce qu'il est nécessaire de
nous protéger face au développement des
usages aujourd'hui non régulés
je tiens également à saluer le travail
du rapporteur Claude Kern qui a intégré
le principe de l'obligation de recourir
à des titres d'accès infalsifiables afin
de mieux lutter contre les fraudes
perpétrées en recourant à de faux
billets désormais les billets devront
être nominatifs dématérialiser et
infalsifiable pour les manifestations
sportives de grande ampleur dont la
jauge sera fixée par des crayons
conseils d'État autre avancée de la
commission culture qui me semble
importante à signaler le rapport de la
Cour des comptes à l'issue des Jeux
Olympiques et apparemment et
paralympique qui devra faire le bilan de
l'organisation du coup et de l'héritage
de cet événement et être remis au
Parlement dès le mois d'octobre 2025
ce rapport devra également retracer
l'ensemble des coûts engagés par l'État
et les collectivités ce qui est ce qui
permet bien sûr une transparence et nous
la devons à nos concitoyens enfin
et j'en conclurai par là je veux
simplement saluer l'amendement proposé
par la rapporteur canaillé et que nous
avons adopté en séance qui prévoit
expressément l'application du projet de
loi dans les territoires ultramarins
sont renvoyés à une ordonnance c'est
notre collègue la natte et Touni
particulièrement rassurée par ces
dispositions pour la Polynésie
pour toutes ces raisons qui ont permis
d'améliorer sensiblement la qualité de
votre projet de loi madame la ministre
le groupe Union centriste votre a
favorablement à ce texte je vous
remercie chers collègues de votre
attention merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jean-Louis Masson pour la
Réunion administrative des sénateurs qui
ne figure sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
vous avez la parole
Madame le Ministre chers collègues
ce second texte que nous examinons
puisque il y a plusieurs années nous
avons déjà eu un vote sur l'organisation
des Jeux Olympiques
et je l'espère le dernier j'espère que
maintenant les choses seront bouclées
c'est un test qui n'est pas fondamental
mais qui apporte un certain nombre
d'ajouts et qui incorpore également
certains nombres de dispositions à
caractère plus ou moins
expérimental qui s'ajoute finalement
à gérer au problème spécifique des Jeux
Olympiques car ces mesures que l'on
ajoute sont des mesures qui sont
supplémentaires et qui viennent je
dirais
compléter finalement l'arsenal alors je
voudrais assister simplement sur la
problématique
des aspects de sécurité je pense pour ma
part que si pour les Jeux Olympiques
on estime qu'il y a un certain nombre de
dispositions à caractère sécuritaire qui
doivent être prises en matière sportive
et bien il est logique il y a une
certaine cohérence à ce que ces
dispositions ne s'appliquent pas
seulement aux Jeux olympiques et donc
moi je ne vois aucun inconvénient à ce
que les dispositions en question et un
caractère un peu plus large que ce qui
est que ce qui est strictement sensu ce
qui correspond au strictosensus aux Jeux
Olympiques alors c'est tout
particulièrement le cas de la vidéo
surveillance et
ce texte apporte un petit complément et
je dirais
renforce finalement les aspects de
sécurité on a vu à de nombreuses
reprises dans les stades et il faut on
n'a pas été obligé d'attendre des Jeux
Olympiques pour voir s'il y avait des
problèmes et donc
a fortiori ce qui sera fait pour les
Jeux Olympiques je me réjouis de ce que
cela puisse être étendu
premier temps il y a quand même un
aspect on oublie trop souvent que les
Jeux Olympiques ne se passeront pas
seulement à Paris mais se passeront
également dans un certain nombre de
villes où il va y avoir une sorte de
décentralisation soit pour
l'entraînement soit carrément pour
l'organisation de certaines épreuves et
dans ces villes c'est pas toujours dans
les villes c'est parfois même dans des
petites villes qui sont en bordure de
grandes agglomérations d'agglomérations
et il y a une problématique car on parle
d'installer de la visiosurveillance de
de faire des investissements mais il est
évident que la problématique pour Paris
et la région parisienne n'est pas
obligatoirement la même que la
problématique pour les petites communes
et les je dirais qui sont en province et
lesquels peuvent être confrontés
pour les petites communes et moyennes
communes
lesquelles si elles ont un équipement
utilisé peuvent être confrontés à des
difficultés or il y a quand même un
point qu'il serait important d'examiner
c'est le financement des équipements de
vidéo surveillance car il y a un moment
donné il va y avoir des dépenses et les
communes vont être obligées de faire des
dépenses et ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que ces dépenses seront faites pour des
Jeux Olympiques donc pour quelque chose
à caractère national et il est important
que les régions puissent les
subventionner et malheureusement
actuellement les régions n'ont pas le
droit de subventionner l'équipement des
communes en visioconférence et c'est je
pense un problème important j'ai pas
assez de temps pour pour m'expliquer
plus longtemps mais ça suffira
la parole est maintenant président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe du
Rassemblement
vous avez la parole
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
alors certes contrairement à mon
collègue Bernard chalet intervenu pour
notre groupe la discussion générale je
ne suis plus un grand sportif même si il
était quelque peu de manière et surtout
surtout je continue à suivre la
passivité et performances des deux
sportives nationaux c'est l'occasion de
saluer le parcours de handballeur lors
du dernier Championnat du Monde qui
s'achevait ce week-end à Stockholm qui
fit de près l'épopée de footballeur en
décembre malheureusement nous prenons
trop l'habitude de perdre les finales
espérons donc quand on donne du fond et
c'est coéquipiers du XV de France
sortiront vainqueur l'automne et qu'une
pluie de médailles
et qu'une fille de médaille ça va pour
les joséphines
j'aimerais réjouis que notre pays soit
organisateur des Jeux Olympiques et para
olympique même si un point de vue
strictement sportif
j'aurai quelques regrets dans le choix
opéré par le CIO notamment au sujet des
nouvelles disciplines à introduite le
Skateboard plutôt que le karaté
le breakdance plutôt que la pétanque
je n'aurais pas caché ma ma satisfaction
si ça avait été l'inverse mais sans
doute et c'est une question de
génération plutôt banlieue
toujours est-il que chacun a ses
conscience du défi que représente
l'organisation d'un événement pour notre
pays et qui impératif que parier la
France accueille sans accroc cet
événement un accueille sans accroc
sportif d'abord c'est une nécessité qui
vaut le sur le plan des soins avec
l'installation de son de santé dans le
village olympique paralympique c'est une
nécessité qui vaut également du point de
vue de la lutte contre le dopage de
nouvelles techniques d'analyse de
Vendôme qui est autorisé à l'occasion
des Jeux c'est une bonne chose nous
considérons que les dispositifs proposés
sont relativement équilibrés et que leur
pérennisation comme le propose c'est du
Sénat n'est pas n'a pas être crainte un
accueil sans accroc également pour la
sécurité et la sécurité des personnes je
n'avais pas refaire le débat des
articles de ce projet toutefois un
attire particulièrement l'attention
qu'au bon nombre dans cette hémicycle
nous avons des craintes quant aux
dispositions de l'article 7
la peur d'une société sur surveillance
automatisée à la mode en Vienne et
souvent agité de manière excessive mais
il y a des fois où l'épouvantail se
justifient c'est le cas ici parce qu'en
même temps que les algorithmes et autres
intelligence artificielle s'affirme
avait l'espoir de plus de sécurité
lui-même s'efface et son discernement
aussi bien entendu le projet présenté
mesuré il marque même une satisfaction
qui signera pas par question de
reconnaissance faciale mais nous
concerne trop bien cette méthode des
petits pas nous savons comment les
choses progressent par palier
l'introduction c'est d'intelligence
artificielle risque d'être une première
marche jusqu'au jour au sous couvert
d'un nouvel évènement que les
algorithmes seuls n'auraient pas pu
prévoir il faudra aller au-delà
seulement je ne crois pas que les
dispositif aurait permis d'éviter les
drames qui ont eu lieu dans notre pays
je pense à l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
aux attentats servi Hebdo ou la nuit du
13 novembre 2015 pas plus l'algorithme
Laurent empêché au mois de mai dernier
lors du stade du match Stade de France
c'est en juin enchevénement des causes
imprévisibles pour reprendre les mots de
la préfecture plus encore le sentiment
profond que l'idée présentant
l'innovation technologique comme une
solution évidente demeure une chimère
potentiellement dangereuse en me
retardera peut-être que comme pour le
choix entre la breakdance et le la
pétanque ce n'est qu'une affaire de
générations donc auquel cas j'espère
simplement que vous aurez raison mais
accordez-moi le privilège de douter vous
comprenez donc mes chers collègues que
même si nous voterons ce texte nous
ferons et que certaines retenues notre
groupe RDSE rappelle souvent sur
l'attachement à la liberté et aux
libertés nous savons qu'elle sonne nos
limites d'ailleurs nous avons déposé une
série amendement visant à durcir les
conditions d'usage par l'administration
du mécanisme de surveillance
algorithmique nous regretterons nous
regrettons qu'il n'est pas trouvé
d'ici favorable au sein du Sénat
toutefois nous sommes pas obtus si nous
avons devant nous par convaincu d'autres
ont été retenus et participeront à mieux
garantir les droits et libertés de nos
concitoyens au regard si tous ces
éléments l'article 7 remodeler offre
davantage de satisfaction que sa
rédaction initiale malgré les réserves
que j'ai mis d'évoquer sur notre sujet
ce projet de loi introduit la
possibilité de mettre en place du
scanner corporel à entrer les enceintes
dans lesquelles est organisé une
manifestation sportive récréative ou
culturelle nous sommes satisfaits du
travail du Sénat qui a également su
amélioré le dispositif initial notamment
avec l'adoption commission de
l'avendement de notre collègue Maryse
Carrère je dirais également un mot du
volley pénal de cette ce projet le texte
initial que nous a été soumis renforcer
les sanctions des violences commises à
l'occasion des manifestations sportives
notre assemblée ces positionner en
faveur de davantage de fermeté
en compte je ne crois pas qu'il faut y
admettre de souplesse particulière
notamment au regard de la nature
médiatique et systématique et des
violences dans le sport et en
particulier dans l'espace enfin et cela
changera bon propos je veux dire notre
satisfaction à l'adoption de la main de
l'amendement de notre collègue Nathalie
Delattre que le groupe RDSE soutenait
largement et nous a partagé sa crainte
devoir disparaître des plages à l'issue
des Jeux Olympiques le corps du maître
nageurs sauveteur CRS la position du
gouvernement cette question nous rassure
et nous retrouverons les CRS donc même
nageurs sur les plages en 2025 ainsi
pour toutes ces raisons pour comprendre
que le groupe RDSE dans sa grande
majorité votera en faveur de ce projet
de loi
merci monsieur le président
j'ai donné la parole de notre collègue
Agnès cadaillé pour le groupe les
républicains
monsieur président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues rapporteur du texte
je m'exprimerai aujourd'hui en tant que
membre de mon groupe l'organisation de
ces jeux présentera des défis
considérables tant sur le plan de la
sécurité que de l'organisation des
compétitions ou encore de la lutte
contre le dopage les jeux de paris 2024
après plus d'un siècle d'attente devrait
rassembler près de 13,5 millions de
spectateurs 4 milliards de
téléspectateurs et se tiendront sur 37
sites à travers la France des berges de
la Seine au rivage du Pacifique en
Polynésie française en outre ce projet
de loi nous parvient quelques mois à
peine après les événements de la finale
de la Ligue des champions au Stade de
France le 28 mai 2022 ces événements
avaient alors conduit la commission des
lois et de la culture à consacrer une
série d'auditions sous l'égide des
présidents buffets et Lafont le rapport
qu'il rédigère alors comprenez un
ensemble de réflexions et préconisations
utiles
contribuèrent grandement à guider notre
à vos actuels c'est donc avec une
conscience des enjeux et un esprit de
responsabilité que nous avons abordé ce
texte déposé par le Gouvernement
ce dernier comprenait trois pans
principaux le premier concerné les
problématiques de santé et de dopage le
second les questions de sécurité et le
dernier un certain nombre d'ajustements
plus variés premièrement sur la question
du dopage il nous faut il nous fut
initialement proposé de déroger à la
législation française pendant la durée
des jeux afin de nous conformer aux
exigences du CIO en matière de lutte
antidopage c'est à dire de nous aligner
sur le code mondial antidopage après
avoir soigneusement étudié la question
nous avons privilégié une mise en
conformité plus durable du droit
français aux normes internationales
entouré de garanties appropriée à la
nature des examens des caractéristiques
génétiques dont il est question grâce à
cela la France sera en conformité avec
le droit international pour les futurs
événements sportifs
après tous ces jeux n'ont pas vocation à
être la dernière compétition
internationale à se tenir dans notre
pays avant d'éventuelles nouveaux jeux
au siècle prochain toujours dans le
domaine du dopage nous avons également
fait en sorte de conforter les
dispositions spécifiques à la Polynésie
française en bonne intelligence
sénatoriale avec la collectivité de
Polynésie et le gouvernement
le deuxième pan du texte qui fut plus
discuté consacré à la question de la
sécurité cette dernière est un enjeu
majeur d'autant plus que certains
événements tels que la cérémonie
d'organes d'ouverture organisait le long
de la Seine nécessiteront un déploiement
inédit de nos forces de police et de
deux gendarmerie afin d'en garantir le
bon déroulement
pardon l'expérience récente du Stade de
France doit nous servir de piqûre de
rappel et prévenir de toute menace il
nous faut être exigeant et au
rendez-vous à temps c'est pour cela que
nous avons retenu l'utilisation de
traitement algorithmique pour les images
des caméras l'expérimentation de ce
dispositif de vidéoprotection
intelligentes pour réconstituer un atout
indéniable dans l'identification et la
neutralisation rapide des risques liés
aussi bien au terroristes qu'au
mouvement de foule inopiné naturellement
nos débats tout au long des travaux
autour de ce texte l'ont montré l'emploi
de telles technologies a pu générer des
inquiétudes que nous comprenons le
rapport de nos collègues d'oblress de
belney et du Rhin c'était d'ailleurs
abondamment penché sur les tenants et
les aboutissants de ces technologies
pour cette raison nous avons
perfectionné le dispositif en affinant
son objet en améliorant l'information du
public et en entoura en entourant
l'usage des données col de garantie
supplémentaire dans ces conditions
l'expérimentation de la vidéoprotection
intelligente devrait simultanément
permettre de contribuer à la
sécurisation des jeux et nous permettre
d'évaluer en situation réelle les
mérites de cette technologie
notre démarche similaire pour d'autres
dispositifs tel que le recours au
scanner à honte minimétrique ou la mise
en conformité avec le droit européen de
la protection des données personnelles
par ailleurs les travaux menés avec la
commission de la culture autour des
outils de lutte contre les entrées
frauduleuses ou violences en récidives
dans les enceintes sportives ont
également permis de renforcer
considérablement le texte initial
une question importante a également
retenu notre attention dès les auditions
même si elle demeurait nécessairement
peu présente dans le texte lui-même la
question des coûts et de l'héritage
la candidature parisienne se voulait
offrir comme les plus sombres et
écologique de l'histoire récente grâce à
l'usage d'infrastructures existantes et
à la mise en place d'un héritage durable
et utile dans les mots même de madame la
ministre devant notre assemblée c'est
effectivement un impératif si nous
souhaitons conserver l'adhésion des
Français à l'organisation des Jeux c'est
pour assurer cette transparence
démocratique que nous avons prévu la
remise par la Cour des comptes d'un
rapport sur les coûts et l'héritage des
jeux en outre et cela relevait presque
autant de la rigueur juridique que de
l'esprit olympique et paralympique nous
avons souhaité élargir la possibilité
d'obtenir de nouvelles autorisations de
stationnement pour les taxis accessibles
aux personnes à mobilité réduite
nos travaux ont donc permis vous le
voyez de grandement consolider le texte
initial en le rendant à la fois
juridiquement plus solide et cohérent et
plus protecteur sur le plan des libertés
individuelles et si cette tâche est
effectivement ardue nous ne pouvons
qu'encourager tous les acteurs des Jeux
Olympiques et para olympiques de 2024 en
leur rappelant les paroles du baron
Pierre de Coubertin chaque difficulté
rencontrée doit être l'occasion d'un
nouveau progrès
542 c'est le nombre de jours qui nous
séparent de la grande fête universelle
du sport soyons au rendez-vous vous
l'aurez compris notre groupe votre a
donc ce projet de loi
merci ma chère collègue
[Applaudissements]
chers collègues il va être procédé dans
les conditions prévues par l'article 56
de notre règlement au scrutin public
solennel sur l'ensemble du projet de loi
dont l'intitulé
et modifier projet de loi relatif aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques de 2024
et portant diverses autres dispositions
de scrutin est ouvert
mais je vous invite
à insérer votre carte de votre dans le
terminal et de lui laisser jusqu'à la
fin du vote
quelqu'un demande encore à voter
oui
plus personne ne demande à voter donc
le scrutin avec l'eau
résultat du scrutin 113 donc de votants
338 donc de suffrages exprimés 273 pour
l'adoption 245 contre 25 le Sénat a donc
adopté
[Applaudissements]
même le ministre vous donne la parole
merci monsieur le président
pour l'attention personnelle que vous
portez à ce chantier olympique et
paralympique mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais évidemment au nom
du gouvernement et avec mes collègues
Clément bonne notre ministre des
Transports me fait
l'amitié d'être présent à mes côtés pour
ce moment important également au nom du
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
je voudrais vous remercier pour cette
adoption la saluer vous dire que c'est
évidemment un jalon indispensable dans
notre préparation aux Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques remercier évidemment
l'ensemble des membres des commissions
qui ont été très à la manœuvre dans
l'amélioration de ce texte et dans cette
adoption merci Agnès canailler merci
Claude Kern merci Florence lasarade pour
la minutie avec laquelle vous avez
travaillé votre engagement derrière tout
ça ainsi pour la richesse de nos
échanges les apports importants de la
part du Sénat je pense à la mise en
place de cette billetterie infalsifiable
dématérialisée je pense aux équilibres
trouvés sur la prévention de toutes les
formes de violence dans nos stades ainsi
que le renforcement de notre dispositif
contre le contre le dopage
certes pas réussi à vous convaincre tous
mais je sais que tous vous êtes engagés
derrière la réussite de ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques et je
voulais aussi vous dire que j'avais été
très attentive à vos interventions pour
aussi placer plus largement que les Jeux
Olympiques la place du sport un peu plus
au cœur de notre société monsieur le
sénateur requie le rugby je vous
remercie beaucoup et à très bientôt
je vais maintenant suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à
15h50 pour l'examen de la promotion de
loi visant régularisée le pluie de la
communauté de communes du Bas-Chablais